hello and welcome to the lobby gamespot
weekly video game chat show
live on twitch.tv forward slash gamespot
on gamespot.com and in your ear holes
whenever you want to via itunes and all
those other podcast things scott
butterworth how are you doing my friend
hey doing all right how are you man
great great to have you back on the show
thank you to be here you seem to have
been very busy over the past couple
weeks reviewing many video games yeah
well and traveling a bit too like i went
to north carolina to see law breakers
which is actually really fun and i
played gears right before that so yeah
keep keeping busy yeah yeah we've got
you on to talk about battleborn in a
little second uh which is out today
finally aaron sampson's here as well how
are you doing you've been playing video
games yeah i decided to get into ark
survival evolved oh have you really yeah
i i actually really like it a lot and i
also really hate it a lot and they're
related okay explain to me as the as
yeah the person who hasn't played this
but has played a bunch of these types of
games like i like the forest a lot um
rust was another goodie what's what's
unique with arc arcs really old is new
it's they take all the old mmo mechanics
like
just really making everything difficult
for you and having to learn the hard way
and having to go loot your body when you
die from old mmos and they recycle it
with dinosaurs and really pretty island
and it's actually a lot of fun it's one
of those games where when you die it's
your fault have you played the
multiplayer free-to-play thing that they
put out as well i'm trying to study up
enough in the main game so that i feel
like i can compete if i have to craft
and fight other players so i'm just i'm
just fighting dinosaurs right now yeah
it's been interesting it seems like the
steam reaction to that i i apologize if
i forget the name it's our squirrel of
the fittest survivors okay um hasn't
been very good so survival of the
craftiest probably yeah whoever can
craft the fastest uh we're gonna talk
about a lot of games here none of which
involve crafting whatsoever battleborn
call of duty battlefield overwatch it is
a first person melange on today's show
thank you so much to everyone for
watching live on twitch um and
everywhere else we are going to be in
the comments if you have any questions
make sure you get them in there at
daniel dwyer if you can i'm here hello
and you can i'll make sure to ask our
gentleman friends here uh first of all
all right it's finally out
randy pitchford's been talking this game
up at pax as i feel since the dawn of
time something like that yeah gearbox
software's first new game in a little
while i guess they had the pre-sequel
came out a couple years ago but yeah
first sort of big game in about four
years yes yeah borderlands 2 was end of
2012 so yeah about four years i mean
you're right pre-sequel happened in
between but that was
like sort of this weird in-between game
that was pretty fun but it wasn't
it was just sort of an iteration on an
existing game they didn't really invent
new mechanics or anything was just like
here's some more lenses like a filler
between like before the next installment
so yeah this is the first big new thing
and then they were busy i think
publishing um home world as well i think
they did a couple of little bits and
bobs there but yeah in alien isolation
and of course they've been some other
stuff yeah there was a lot of dlc for
borderlands there was a lot of
was really good so those fans were
satiated for a while and um it's got to
be interesting to see how many of them
make the transition to battleborn so
you've been playing for the past couple
of weeks on the beta and stuff your
review and progress is live on the psych
now yeah went up yesterday okay they
said the review embargo yesterday but
unfortunately the servers weren't live
yet so even though the review embargo
expired we couldn't get on and play
competitive multiplayer so that's mainly
what i'm doing now before i put up the
full review later this week cool uh so i
guess let's pick your brain about how
you're feeling about it sure all things
considered and hoping that the sort of
online infrastructure is working fine uh
so yeah right from the top what's your
take on this you've been playing for a
good long while now yeah what are the
modes you're enjoying i guess for people
who don't know much about the game sort
of what is the meat and potatoes of
balboa yeah so i mean as as we mentioned
at the top of the show it's the first
person shooter as with everything with
it's coming out this month so any first
person shooters yeah we're gonna get as
long as possible without mentioning the
o word we'll talk about it later on
we'll get we'll get there um
but what's sort of the big hook for
battleborn for people who haven't been
following is there are 25 playable
characters all of whom have different
abilities and weapons and all this
different stuff and and only a handful
are really traditional shooter
characters that are you know hold right
you're left trigger to aim down sight
you know pull right trigger to fire i
mean there are a lot of melee characters
a lot of support characters and there's
one character who's real his only really
job is is to run around and just heal
everyone um so it's this huge variety of
mechanics and play styles and gameplay
loops that it's it's different for every
single character um the thing that i
discovered is
if you go into
a mission or into multiplayer without
having uh read up on your character
having used your character before you'll
probably end up feeling very lost uh
because they are so different you'll not
you won't necessarily know what you're
what you're doing but once you figure
out a character it's it's generally
pretty simple uh the the gameplay is
pretty light
very fast-paced very chaotic um very
much a classic run and gun kind of
arcadey shooter as opposed to something
that's like a little more thoughtful or
cover based um there's a lot about the
design that just encourages you to keep
pressing forward and just run at your
enemies and you know every character has
infinite ammo there's no fall damage you
can sprint and reload at the same time
so it's very much about just fast-paced
gameplay and so i guess one question
that's coming in a lot hasson mentioned
here is um what's the sort of
single-player component of this game so
obviously there is a large multiplayer
component in that there is like
competitive stuff there's cooperative
stuff
where are we talking in terms of modes
here yeah so there are eight there's a
prologue and then eight
sort of campaign missions okay that are
very clearly designed to be played
cooperatively you can technically play
them solo like you can have to be
certain characters okay like yeah you
can't go in as a support character and
get through the missions easily you
won't you just won't be able to make it
through i mean several of the the
missions involve um sort of point
defense sections where you have waves of
enemies coming you have to defend
something and if you don't have more
than just yourself you can't physically
be in enough places to win or you'll
have like bosses that can fly and if you
don't have a character with projectile
attacks you're kind of screwed into the
land and you're probably not going to
survive so yeah i mean i the first time
i beat borderlands borderlands 2 i've
soloed the entire thing and i actually
really liked it even though that game is
designed to be cooperative this game i
would really strongly recommend not
playing solo it is meant to be played
with other people it drastically changes
the momentum and just sort of the fun
factor even yeah um so play with other
people but yeah so there are eight of
those types of missions that are meant
to be played cooperatively and then
there's competitive multiplayer as well
so it's really just those eight missions
that's the single player or campaign
component how long does it take
each mission is anywhere from half an
hour to an hour uh depending on the
mission i mean i think the longest one
takes about an hour the shortest about
half an hour and most of them land
somewhere in between yeah it's another
reason to take people with you because
the missions are very long and if you're
doing it by yourself it can get a bit
longer it drags are we talking about
sort of similar to titanfall or
something where there isn't they're not
necessarily done in a linear fashion
correct you can kind of do them in any
order they feel like raids they feel
like raids or strikes or something like
that where they're they're standalone
they i mean there are loose story
elements framing what's going on and
depending on the characters that you
bring in you'll get different banter and
a lot of that's actually really well
written it may not be to everyone's
taste but if you enjoy the humor in
borderlands there's a really strong
chance you're gonna enjoy the humor here
and it does give it a lot of character i
mean this is very much like the saturday
morning cartoon of games yeah it's it's
light and it's funny and silly and goofy
uh can be totally immature but it's
usually stupid in clever ways that's
kind of fun one cool little touch about
it too is there's 25 characters but they
all have recorded dialogue right and
it's all different so they'll all react
to like a lot of the missions are escort
the talky robot
and they'll all like react to the robot
differently depending on who they are i
mean you can really tell they kind of
pour their heart and soul into the
backstories of these characters there's
a really funny mission where you're
escorting a robot who doesn't know it's
going to die and like some characters
are like feel pity and some characters
just don't care it's like another one of
the robot characters totally relates to
him like it's really funny how they all
act differently in the campaign dumb as
hell and thirsty for death yeah oh it's
good it's funny it's it's sort of cut
every way here in the office talking to
some people like mary for instance
really enjoyed the stories in the first
year borderlands um but hasn't enjoyed
the sort of the the
the story and the dialogue in this one
it falls a little too close to a
saturday morning cartoon i think she was
saying kind of this morning um i wasn't
really super into borderlands but there
are like shades of this thing that i
kind of was a little bit into um you've
talked a lot about i guess what's sort
of on offer how does it play though like
how engaging is it is it a game you keep
going back to for us and something you
were just reviewing like i said the the
variety really comes from uh all of the
different characters we were talking
about this just before we went live uh
in my mind it you know a lot of games
will give you new abilities or weapons
as you play like you play zelda you get
new stuff oh you have the hook shot now
that opens up new options for gameplay
new mechanics that you can use this game
kind of does the same thing but each new
mechanic is built into a new character
so as you unlock new characters you
suddenly have new things you can do uh
so if you get sick of playing as a
particular you know melee character you
can switch to more of a sniper range
character and suddenly it's a completely
different game i mean the loops are very
different there's a character melka who
has like this gauntlet in one hand and a
automatic pistol on the other and her
loop is she needs to get up close and
melee somebody so that they're like
poisoned and then her gun is more
effective on them okay so she needs to
get in and then get back so that she can
like swipe them but then not take too
much damage but then their other
characters are the exact opposite who
they just need to get in and like be
right in people's faces the whole time
but then there are sniper characters so
yeah if you get sick of somebody just
switch somebody new and that's where the
variety comes from i think one of the
biggest differences though as opposed to
borderlands is that you're asked to
upgrade your character every time you
play yes so your character basically
starts at zero you upgrade through i
think there's ten initial ones and then
as you play as you play more with that
character you actually unlock more
things that you can unlock in that tree
um very much in the style that's
probably one of the biggest like moba
style apps this game has yes so it that
upgrade as you go is new to borderland
style gameplay yeah but the shooting and
the floatiness and the lack of fall
damage like a lot of it will feel very
familiar to people who play borderlands
so i think
you know you're getting used to that
character but the actual
feel of it will be familiar for people
uh so obviously you've talked about the
there's the single player aspect which
are kind of like
more linear uh instances or whatever
then there is the competitive aspect
which is there's like three different
types of modes yeah two three modes two
of them are quite in the sort of realm
of mobile where this creep and whatnot
and one of them sort of a little bit
different right yeah so the
the mode that for me i think is going to
have the most longevity or this may be
the most interesting is also the most
moba inspired it's called incursion okay
basically two teams of five are trying
to escort their little minions to a
grinder at the other end of the level
and they have to destroy the other
team's minions before they get to their
grinder uh it's a point battle so
whoever can successfully escort the most
minions wins um and yeah so just that
structure of the in-match leveling and
guiding these minions and having all of
these different types of characters and
so it's not necessarily symmetrical uh
it does end up feeling at least
structurally a bit like a moba though
the gameplay is closer to like a
borderlands first-person shooter is that
fun
yeah i i find it really fun i mean it
definitely allows the characters to
shine a bit more i mean i found the
enemies in the
campaign to be somewhat mindless and
it's it's fine i mean you can almost
think of those missions as as being
practice or almost like a canvas on
which you can you know
test out all of these different
abilities these characters have and it's
kind of just fun and everything they can
do is on display but then in multiplayer
you're suddenly matched up against other
heroes with equally powerful abilities
and weapons so that's when you kind of
have to really dig into the nuances of
the characters and find different
pairings and um different you know
complementary tactics within a team uh
so we'll talk to some of the negative
points in a second uh groups you ask a
quick question though let's get it out
of the way any microtransactions in this
bad boy not that i'm aware of uh it
doesn't even really seem like it's dlc i
know that for like characters and stuff
yeah and i think they are planning on
doing cosmetic items but none of that's
even in the game currently i'm not even
sure how they would do that there's like
a loot crate system for mods the mods
are almost equivalent to the shield mods
in borderlands where
like you you get mods and then as you
farm crystals and in various matches
you enabled and activate the mods and
they actually can balance out certain
characters like certain range characters
don't have much health or shields and
you can unlock mods through the loot
crate system
to bolster their their strengths and
weaknesses and then you know short their
weaknesses so and to be clear that is
separate from the in-match leveling
there's sort of like three different
levels of progression in this game which
is very confusing yeah we've already
delved into some of the specifics on
this bad boy let's not get too much yeah
it's a very deep rabbit hole uh let's
talk to some of the sort of the
shortcomings i guess i played a bunch
this morning um i played last night as
well uh and was very frustrated that i
had to do that tutorial mission twice
especially because you cannot skip that
introductory cutscene which is like one
of the gravest like
like sins in game design um
i'm sort of
it's a game that like i don't think i'm
very much into these sort of loot
shooters anyway like i was kind of into
borderlands a little bit but i don't
really play alongside other people that
that much i prefer sort of shorter you
know team-based games um or like
multiplayer one-on-one sort of games
that like wrap up in like 10-15 minutes
so i'm not really sure if it's for me
necessarily but there was a bunch of
things about this game that just did not
like sit well with me like for instance
a lot of the game seems to be based
around either standing on capture points
or wait killing wave after wave of the
same enemies over and over again does
that get boring at all
i mean it absolutely can the like like i
said for me the campaign missions are
almost more like just practice
again if you think of them as a canvas
on which these characters can paint with
their wild abilities uh then they're
kind of more palatable but you're
totally right that it is pretty
unimaginative go here defend the thing
wave q wave one wave two wave three it's
it's pretty routine a lot of the time
yeah and so you're not wrong about that
i mean it becomes a little more dynamic
and competitive multiplayer but even
that there are only three modes and
really only one of those is truly sort
of memorable in its structure i mean one
of them's just a really generic capture
and hold point guarding
uh mode which is you know pretty
standard training multiple which is fine
i mean every game kind of needs
something like that but it's hard to get
excited about it really what are some of
the shortcomings you've sort of come
across as the reviewer for this game i
mean the one that i think is the most
obvious and and to my mind one of the
reasons this game has had a hard time
getting any traction is that there's
just no real cohesion to it feels very
scattered i mean it pulls from every
influence imaginable and and not just
even in terms of the character i mean
obviously the characters are all very
different and you have everything from
like high fantasy influence stuff to
very sci films win stuff but even aside
from that look at the first 20 minutes
of the game so you mentioned that
there's the mandatory sort of opening
mission yeah just within the first 20
minutes of the game you get this sort of
like
american anime rotoscoping cut scene
thing yeah like dion flux kind of thing
yeah but then there's also music yeah
and then there's in-game cut scenes and
then there's later there's a motion
graphic all within the first 20 minutes
of the game it's like they they just
said yes to every idea it lacks an
identity and it doesn't really kind of
gel in on a lot of levels and in terms
of the gameplay as well in that first
thing they try and do their best shot i
guess to sort of expose you to a lot of
the different mechanisms you're going to
play in this game yeah and there are so
many of them and they're so
varied and disparate and none of them
seem that important but obviously all of
them are a little bit important so
you're like collecting money to buy on
you know putting turrets in places and
you're you know leveling up your
character's abilities which when you hit
that button to view your character's
abilities it's just a wall of like
so many what crazy wall of text it's
just like you know obviously you can't
babysit everyone and there are certain
games where like you need to like dive
into that stuff and just figure it out
and stop being a jerk about it but
there's something about this one it was
just like there's too much of that [ __ ]
happening i don't know no i i think
you're exactly right i can absolutely
relate to that and i think what almost
makes that worse
is that once you do figure all of that
stuff out because you can i mean it's
you know it is a pain and you do have to
read a bunch of stuff and i recommend
you do because you'll be better off than
just
feeling like you're totally clueless and
helpless in the middle of a match but
once you figure everything out once you
know a character's loop
you realize that it's kind of
superficial i mean the analogy that i've
been making to other people is that for
a lot of games or for something that's
well designed it's generally easy to
learn and difficult to master like
rocket league you know it's immediately
intuitive but it takes a long time to
get really good at aerials and stuff i
feel like this game in a lot of ways is
the exact opposite right where there's a
high barrier to entry where you're just
feeling confused and overwhelmed but
once you get a handle on it it's kind of
like oh okay well now i realize i'm just
kind of spamming the same attack and
waiting for the cooldown timer to refill
and once that does then i trigger my
special again and then i'm just spamming
the attack again and each character has
their own kind of pattern and once you
figure out that pattern that's it that's
kind of all you do right and you can
switch to a new character and it kind of
refreshes and becomes fun again but only
for a while and it's so you can
absolutely have some light fun with this
and it is crazy and frantic but you're
right that there's this weird learning
curve and then it plateaus and doesn't
stay fun um let's briefly talk about the
elephant in the room uh i think it's no
coincidence that blizzard decided to put
the overwatch open beta the day this
game comes out yes savage obviously
these games are like there are lots of
similarities in in terms of their sort
of colorful vibrant first-person
shooters which have a focus on heroes
almost in terms of everything else
they're completely disparate games like
team overwatch is very much a team
fortress inspired class shooter and this
is sort of doing its own thing slightly
more towards paragon and and then very
like broad in terms of it's like
single-player narrative and all these
other bits and bobs um you gotta say
though
as a consumer if you're gonna spend 60
bucks on a shooter i mean doom is out in
a couple of weeks as well yeah um do you
think gearbox might be a little bit
worried with this one oh i mean yes i
would assume that they are i mean that's
that's some pretty stiff competition and
any month where you have you know a
number of high-profile aaa releases
that's already going to be worrying i
would assume for a publisher but
especially when it's similar enough that
consumers aren't necessarily going to
discern between them even if as you
pointed out they are actually pretty
different games
yeah i would have to assume the gearbox
is is a little nervous and honestly it
seems like no one's that excited about
the otterborn that i'm seeing including
borderlands fans and it's kind of a
shame because i i do think battleborn is
fun and and it's doing some creative
things and a lot of work and a lot of
really cool ideas went into it even if
it doesn't work out perfectly as we were
just discussing um it is kind of a shame
that it's not getting at least a little
more love from fans but
yeah yeah it's a strange one it kind of
feels like a game that
it's it's got it's got all the little
parts but it just doesn't hasn't really
been coming together and it's a when you
think about how long this game might
have been in development you kind of
worry that oh they should have probably
had it down by now but yeah i could see
people connecting with certain
characters in the game like i could see
a couple months down the road if you're
a mushroom person you probably like the
mushroom dude right there's some fun
characters in there i think you could
have people connecting with like phoebe
or indy or a couple characters like i
could definitely see people
i could see really landing with certain
people and then them just loving that
one character and wanting to play one
character and showing up at comic-con
dressed as that character like i think
it could have
i could think it could build an audience
over time like be kind of um
you know more long tail yeah sleeper
hitch yeah yeah i mean it needs to it's
a game that's i mean how to play online
right so it is it's like always online
games
and it's also to be fair like i think
the game's longevity has to do with its
multiplayer components and those
multiplayer components were very
difficult for reviewers and for people
with the
the preview build to get a hold of they
just weren't populating the matches
so
i don't know like there might be more of
a long tail in the multiplayer the
single player seemed to come down to
three mission types to score the robot
hold the point with the robot
yeah yeah so yeah multiplayer is where
it's at and we're gonna have to see if
that connects with people cool um when
is the review going up scotty reckon uh
i would say most likely on thursday
that's my best guess all right godspeed
we'll let you out of here to go play
that video game yes scott brother thank
you so much um if anyone has any
questions about the game feel free to
hit up scott on the twitter butterwomp
at butterwomp butterwomb w-o-m-p love it
say spell womp
okay mike my heart is coming in yeah but
now bring it over bro yeah yeah we gotta
give away on today's show as well
cynthia where is fan this awesome let's
bring it in let's put it in yeah you
guys can swap it yeah
uh here give me give me oh you put it
together and everything nice it's made
to be like disassembled so okay
as long as we don't disassemble it like
his head's gonna come off oh yeah sorry
richard can get the shot there this is a
pretty sweet nathan drake uh uncharted
paperweight yeah right max this is a
sideshow collector collectible they only
made 500 of these um it's pretty like we
get the wide shot just to show you how
big it is because i feel like it's uh
yeah yeah it's i mean it's heavy
compared to a mac right there and this
is technically from uncharted 3 but
apparently the person who we might have
sent this to previously never picked it
up so it got sent back about three years
ago um so cynthia's had it by her desk
for all that time it's like incredible
detail like you literally put on like
all these little pieces of clothing and
stuff so if you're into uh uncharted
yeah this is a pretty sweet prize uh we
still have the box fort and everything
so we're gonna take it apart again and
then and
basically send it out to whoever wants
it look at this kalashnikov you can even
take that off um you can take his head
off as well i kind of want to do it yeah
it's pretty easy i'm worried is it
have you done it yeah it's like it's a
square
that didn't happen in the game look at
this if i do that if i do this can i
just like line it up on my head like
like that
i'm tyros
i give everyone raises
double pay next month because it's e3
uh look at this guy yeah it's pretty
good and then also if you want you can
just have that and then have a headless
nathan drake
also available so yeah we're giving this
away if you want to win this um make
sure you follow gamespot on twitter and
retweet the tweet that we've done
tweeted
um and we're gonna give this away i
would be i would assume that this is
north america only as well so
apologies to our portuguese friends uh
let me put this in the back
it's pretty cool right don't break it oh
god did you imagine because you imagined
we just smashed it right now it's like
those twitch streams you've got people
like putting pcs together and they
totally like spill water all over the
mobile oh yeah do that we'll just have
to give away the sailboat
yeah i know right
where's the pikmin it shook a little bit
there yeah we'd have to give away the ss
pikmin josh will not be happy
no he would not be happy he can't stop
us he can't he can just sit there in the
twitch shot with his funny little logo
we can even live stream it through
twitch
get them followers all right we got a
bunch of uh hot first person action to
talk about here so
let's get into it michael maherty do you
like the call of duty
yeah yeah you used to much more what was
your what's your favorite call duty game
first minor warfare or call of duty two
cod four i'll call day two a lot of
people like called two two yeah did you
play it on console yeah that was my
first xbox 360 game i think that's why a
lot of people like it it was uh i worked
at a gamestop back there and
when we were selling 360s everyone was
getting caught too yeah it's like one of
the best like new first place i think it
was because everyone was waiting for
halo 3 or something yeah because it was
called duty 2 like madden 06 or
something and then um perfect dark zero
which yeah didn't really project gotham
racing man in that yeah everyone wanted
that i didn't play that uh aaron what
about yourself you're more of a
battlefield fan but you like called dude
i did i started i went up through i just
played like modern warfare 2 and then at
that point i was like this series has
hit its pinnacle
i don't know if i really need to
continue from here but i know a lot of
people love the black ops series i
played the single player and loved it
i'm at a point now where i actually will
play call of duty for the single player
and i play battlefield for the
multiplayer interesting because i feel
like i've kind of done it
um but i gotta say that was the first
game where i remember you know
modern warfare was the game that kicked
a whole generation out of the world war
ii yes genre totally like that is what
put a fork in world war ii and it's
funny because i feel like we're coming
back around again where now people are
sick of the modern warfare
and we're like coming back to people
asking for world war ii again for sure i
think and people would not have been
surprised if this or i guess the
battlefield reveal will be on thursday
if if either of them went towards world
war ii again uh we'll talk about it
later on the show but uh yeah
interesting to see that uh the news has
come out that uh call of duty infinite
warfare is going to double down on its
space levels and uh is straight up a
game set in space with you know asteroid
mining and and off-world development and
stuff like that did have a sick major
tom trailer it did i was in eminem so no
well
yeah i was at the start i was like okay
fair enough you know good timing uh you
know respect to david bowie but then he
could have eminem doing major time oh
god no no i thought it was it was a
decent trailer the first half of the
trailer i wasn't super hot on but the
second half was a little bit better uh
so let's dive into the the meat and
potatoes of this um
first of all i got a quote here uh uh
which was given directly to gamespot and
infinite war
if infinite warfare
so infinity war god that's going to be
really cool we just call it infinite
duty i feel like they missed a lot of
poop jokes
dude he never stops
all the duty
uh jacob minkoff says the approach that
we've taken with this game the
inspiration don't come from sci-fi or
space in any way the inspiration comes
from war stories this is call of duty we
are talking about warfare and this in
this case infinite warfare what we feel
is that classically told narratives can
take to play can take place in any
settings they are very worried about
saying that this is a sci-fi shooter i
feel like they are worried of losing
their crowd which is like a problem that
activision have with this series is that
it's almost like too big of a seller to
make take any risks uh so what do you
guys think about the fact that they're
going for the sort of
modern warfare future warfare and there
were future future warfare
the livestream
had two very contradictory tones to it
on one hand they said yes multiplayer is
going to take place on other planets and
potentially on space stations but in
like a sentence later they're like oh
but we're not going to change anything
because we don't want to scare off our
crowd basically right what they said so
that makes me worried that they're just
going to change the skybox and the level
design and then keep the same gameplay
whereas i would love it if some
developer
would like change the formula first
person shooters and start doing things
like forget flat maps let's do maps on
like a spherical asteroid or let's do
like variable gravity or let's do
just something like that's different
from these flat static maps we've been
getting for the past decade
like levolution from battlefield wasn't
really that big of a thing call of
duty's had one or two destructible items
in their environment and sometimes
things happen to change routes but like
i would really like one of these
developers to get creative with
multiplayer i mean they dipped their toe
in the water with so with um
the the kevin spacey one i forgot that's
modern
which one advanced advanced warfare
sorry and then blops3 as well they sort
of had some of the you know
titanfall-esque movement in there but
you're right in saying that like you
know we think about call of duty 4
modern warfare as this game that really
broke the genre because it like took it
out of world war ii but actually
though it had that big thematic shift in
terms of its gameplay it also that's
sort of a really changed was that oh it
was the game that like made first of all
a really solid um varied mechanically
single player campaign it wasn't just
having different warfare in different
places there was like different types of
warfare like the ghillie suit stuff and
big massive battles and then sort of
smaller stealthy stuff and then
alongside that they basically invented
the type of multiplayer that we've never
been playing for 10 years so
since then we've had all these tiny
little iterative steps and every once in
a while they take like a bigger little
step or like double down on the zombies
or go towards the future stuff but i
mean mike at this age is a time for them
to
you know marry the thematic
step they're taking here with some
actual changes to how call of duty plays
yeah 100 i don't want it to be i mean
the thing that would get me and a lot of
people interested in the series again is
if they like aaron was saying it's not
just a new paint it's an actual like
functional change they make to the game
like you said like i know they're
talking about zero g combat and they did
have that the beginning of ghosts which
infinity ward also did it wasn't the
best game but
i thought maybe if they did more of that
that would have made them for an
interesting game or at least kind of you
know
change up how we're approaching this
it's not just this stop and pop shooter
right um i'd like them to actually kind
of whatever happened back then because
they had a big audience with their world
war ii shooters but they took a chance
with modern warfare they you know like
you said they implemented this
multiplayer that's become so pervasive
yeah i would love for them to just say
all right screw it let's try something
new and maybe spark another 10 years or
something and for the first four years
that we can be excited again yeah i mean
there's been so much evolution in terms
of first person games in recent years as
well like the open world thing has
completely changed like far cry changed
the rule book a lot like games like
dying light even just like took what
mirror's edge tried to do and then
expanded it out in so many interesting
ways call of duty is still the same like
super hyper linear and i don't really
like i'm cut totally with you i enjoy
playing the single player campaigns in
these but i almost enjoy them a lot
because they're short
like i could not deal with that for 15
hours but i can like deal with it for
like a weekend and it's like it's kind
of fun and a little bit entertaining um
but even in that like they're never
really that the hook really isn't there
that it was back in 2006-7 i mean also
you get used to the adrenaline rush of
these games it becomes normal to you
um when modern warfare first came out i
was it was the only game i played where
i was literally shaking like at the end
of a round because there had never been
multiplayer that intense before but then
by modern warfare 2 is a little bit less
and then black ops came around i was
like whatever like i'm
already immune to this level of crack
right yeah you know it's just like and
then and then it started getting boring
because it was like geez i just walk
around a corner and shoot somebody like
i respawn before my old body hits the
floor and then i do it again and again
and again and again and just
it it lost the intensity because the
intensity was so consistent yeah and i
think it's what you're saying they need
to
somehow bring that level of intensity
in a new way
and i don't know like i can't tell you
what that is i
when you say space to me i get excited i
wanted
battlefront to be more space and that
didn't even have it right so like to me
space is such an amazing palette for
gameplay like you can have ships you can
fight on the halls of ships right you
can fight inside ships you can fight an
asteroid belt i think of games like dead
space for instance like all the various
things they managed to do with that
there's so much you can do when you just
get rid of
the ground
and earth's gravity you know and you
have the future setting but
you know i don't will these guys take
the risk yeah they have their franchise
crowd
yeah yeah and speaking to that they're
sort of having their cake and eating it
because they're deciding to do a
remastered version of you know what many
consider it even the best call of duty
game
certainly in the past you know the
modern era call of duty 4 modern warfare
uh
sockrocker7 asking a question a lot of
people are wondering uh what do you
think about the fact that they're not
allowing people to buy this separately
this is only for people who pre-order
the new game infinite warfare i think
it's telling of what they think might
happen i mean right i think i think a
certain time after release they will
just put it on psn or something or xbox
live but
i'm expecting
this package to come out and i think
modern warfare will hold up and i'm
hoping infinite warfare is better right
but i'm curious as to whether people
will like the new game more than the
game that gets packaged in with it could
you imagine if they sold it separately
and cod 4 sold more yeah i wouldn't i'd
be surprised but it would still be
indicative of where the series has come
since that first really great game yeah
i guess it depends how much they sell it
for as well at the end of that um yeah
final thoughts on that are you guys
excited about the theme sort of stuff
like is it new i mean
you were saying before it is out there
yeah it's shades of another game right
yeah no i sat i saw 33 last year and
they were talking about blops three and
how all the movement mechanics were new
and i was kind of scratching my head
like this is titanfall
and then like
in titanfall's movement mechanics and
then i was watching this trailer and
they were talking about fighting over
colonies and resources and then those
going into space and scratching my head
again going you guys are still chasing
titanfall
so i want to see what titanfall 2 does
respawn to me is a much more exciting
studio at this stage because
it's because it's vincent is actually
there and it's not just his ghost giving
them ideas but
you know they they showed incredible
creativity with titanfall
and i would just love to see what they
can do with that franchise and if we're
talking about space that's where my
head's at right um infinite warfare i'll
i'll give it a chance like all other
call of duty games but they have the
constraint of their past and titanfall
doesn't
so i think titanfall has more potential
wait uh yeah you're right
success is a double-edged sword uh yeah
thank you so much both for talking about
call of duty infinite warfare it's got a
release date as well it is coming out
i'm gonna guess it's november 6th or
something is it it's coming out november
4th for playstation 4 xbox one and pc i
wonder if there'll be special neo
graphics as well i guess there have to
be actually on the playstation 4 because
that's a that's a rule now yeah let us
know are you excited for call of duty
infinite warfare uh put your thoughts in
the comments below all right we're
making a hard shift we've talked about
call of duty it's now time we talk about
the real first person shooter oh yeah
battlefield baby okay battlefield what a
series that's what i thought you're
going to say you weren't what do you
think i was going to say half-life
overwatch we're talking about later yeah
we're talking about you've been playing
i mean another futuristic shooter yes
yes exactly the future where we have god
please tell me anthropomorphized apes
who are able to i mean apes are pretty
i'm there for warfighters already really
aren't they yeah
that's the
one thing they've got going for them you
apes want to live forever
bring me the space man uh no we're gonna
talk about battlefield a storied video
game franchise no no no no no no get rid
of the story
we don't need the story just put a fork
in it done one of my favorite long
lasting memories of this franchise was
battlefield vietnam saying that it was a
campaign on the back of the box and then
it wasn't yeah no they just
took it out of the menu
replaced it instant action bots instead
so let's have a chat we're all fans of
the battlefield series here i thought
it'd be a fun time because we don't
really know what they're going to
announce on thursday so there's no point
in us like talking about it and but what
we can talk about is our love of the
game's past and sort of what is like the
best battlefield game uh the series
started back in i guess it was was it
1999 no 2002 with battlefield 1942 um
which now looks like an iphone game it's
amazing it's crazy if you fire that up i
think it's free on origin or it was for
a while right
yeah because the draw distance that they
had to calculate in that game for the
time was so much longer than you would
think so like there's just all these
crummy
pixel people
shooting at yeah
and were you founded on one iron i
actually
fell in love with the series so i played
i played a little bit of two just
because back then yeah pcs were
expensive and i didn't have a lot of
money at that time
um the first very accessible battlefield
game was bad company and bad company two
yes which is kind of where i've really
fell in love with it but i completely
understand that the generation of people
who played battlefield 2
um on pc who could afford pcs at that
time yeah they fell in love with the
open conquest
just freedom of that game so
it's weird over the years between that
um bad company
and battlefield like hardline and
battlefield
three they've they've cast their net so
wide that i don't know if they can
please all of the people
that they've
like captured yeah i mean when i think
about a great battlefield game you know
1942
was so much fun back then um the desert
combat mod was so popular as well uh big
fan of that which was basically sort of
i think the main reason battlefield 2
went in the direction it did and you're
right like battlefield 2 was the game
which for me like that was the reason to
upgrade your pc like that was when
online connectivity in ireland as well
got like to a stage where you could play
online so when we weren't playing like
games like counter strike at 1.6 and
then eventually cs source like
battlefield 2 was like a game that like
got your processor to like kick in and
also it was a fun online class-based
shooter with like big maps and stuff um
but my favorite game in the series still
hands down is battlefield vietnam i
absolutely adore that game do you play
that one mike oh yeah that was so i got
into the series with uh
desert combat the mod because my brother
was playing it and then he got two
on his pc so i started playing that and
i really got into it like with vietnam
bad company obviously not around the
same time but those were the first two
that were really mine not like right
something i was it was they weren't
hand-me-downs so those are the first two
i really got into i started realizing
how much i like the series and how how
much i like how it set itself apart from
other games there's i mean there's a
certain like
feeling you have when you're flying a
huey and credence is playing oh yeah
like changing the radio station for like
oh i think i'll listen to like deep
purple now yeah that sounds about right
i think vietnam if they did go that
direction and i'm concerned they won't
because of all the other near future
games right now and video game studios
are a lot like film studios where like
they'll sort of deal with their
their competitors are doing right yeah
but if they did vietnam it would it
would check a lot of the boxes like the
photogrammetry from battlefront is
gorgeous and they can do force really
well although they haven't proven they
can do photogrammetry with destruction
which i'm concerned about but yeah like
a vietnam game would have asymmetrical
warfare it would have mild customization
it would have photogrammetry it would
look gorgeous it would have vespas yeah
yeah would have that
humor yeah you're right though that
asymmetrical multiplayer is something
that we sort of haven't had in a in
one of these mainstream multiplayer
shooters in quite a while that was so
much fun like putting like punji sticks
in and having like respawn points like
pop up all over the place so i think it
would be a good direction
uh if they're listening to reddit they
would go world war ii which right i'm
still not convinced people want world
war ii but there has been 10 years of
people who maybe grew up without world
war ii and didn't didn't sit there and
play only world war ii games for a
decade yeah so i don't know that one's a
mixed bag i'm not sure i mean i grew up
on world war ii games and i'm ready for
world war ii
as long as they're sort of they're
they're they're handled effectively um
so we've talked about too we talked
about vietnam we've talked about in 1942
uh as much as i'd love to talk about bad
company next we should actually talk
about 2142 which is one that a lot of
people forget about uh michael not in
your head is that an appreciation or the
opposite it's i have no idea i've played
it for about five total hours at a
friend's house down the street when i
was still pretty busy like playing
you know desert combat like on my
brother's old pc and stuff i don't know
i
i remember playing it i remember it
feeling weird i wasn't used to that
futuristic setting that aesthetic and it
kind of i knew it was a battlefield game
but i wasn't really used to the whole
like shifting between these settings too
much so it was very weird experience i
don't remember much of it it had this
crazy mode it's actually interesting
because you get it you can get inside
mechs and it had a mode called titan
mode yeah do you remember this it was
the like flying space station right now
you had to get up and and
was it either take it out or capture it
i think you had to put a bomb in it or
something so it was like yeah it was
like a space station that was like i
guess the final capture point on a
series of capture points and then yeah
you'd have to go up and and basically
stick obamacare who did that better
star wars battlefront oh yeah that's
true
um 2142 is an interesting one i feel
like it maybe went in a direction like
it did the future warfare thing back
when people didn't want future warfare
and i think it probably suffered from it
um so very people were very happy when
battlefield bad company came around and
this is kind of thought as as the game
that didn't really sell very well
but if you like i have never met anyone
who played battlefield bad comedy who
doesn't love this game that game was
designed uh you know i've followed david
goldfarb and
he was one of the lead designers on that
game and he's always talked about how
that game was designed to be more like
the indiana jones inspired battlefield
right and i think it showed it was the
first one that just wasn't generic mixed
soldier dude one of the best things
about that game was once you got past a
certain point you could just stop
and the guys on your own bad company
would start talking and they would say
really hilarious [ __ ] like you smell
very clean
like he's like i think i'm an angry man
because my mom used too much deep when i
was a kid like you know they just had
these guys sit in the studio if i don't
know how long
two hours and just talk
it was just it was so good and like it
took place in world war ii and it took
place in the present and like
one or two of the levels were were open
like you drove across this giant desert
into these three different bases and
um and you could like if you found an
ammo crate you could just like lay waste
to the rest of the building just for
shits and giggles basically and that was
like going back that was the game that
got a lot of people off of call of duty
like that was the first game that really
appealed to the call of duty crowd well
that was a game that had hey look you
can add a funny interesting story with a
story with likable characters who you
will remember uh in a in a world war ii
game and like or in a way in a world war
two game but just in a first person
military game and i don't think anyone's
done it better since like battlefield
company 2 was wonderful as well the
catch was you had to love rush
which is which i do which is why i love
that game so much
i think it didn't necessarily scratch
the conquest itch that a lot of the
battlefield 2 people had and that's
again like you've got two very different
audiences you've got people who
passionately love rush and every and the
linearness
that those levels bring and then you
have people who passionately love just
the hands off here's my toolbox and a
large open map yeah let's go play some
conquest
so you need to appeal to both of those
audiences to have a successful
battlefield game um after that then
battlefield 3
came out in the end of 2011 and this was
basically the time where ea sort of
clapped their hands together and said
okay enough is enough we're not going to
be the second you know they also ran in
the military first person shooter were
going for um call of duty's throat uh it
had the same sort of battlefield 2 you
know super powerful pc aspect to it
obviously it came out on consoles as
well which the bad company series had as
well and i guess battlefield 2 also came
in on xbox or something but
this was the first time they'd sort of
like really pushed it um i'm not sure if
there's a playstation 2 version
battlefield 2. maybe there was i feel
like there might have been it was a
weird time first person years back then
um but what did you think of battlefield
3 mike were you a fan of that one at all
i remember them pushing really hard for
the fact that it was going to have that
story-driven campaign and at this point
in playing games i was i was primarily
like playing for single player and i
knew battlefield wasn't like the thing i
was expecting a single player story from
but i played that and i couldn't stand
that single player it was it was call of
duty it was crazy how divisive that is
because for some reason i loved it oh
really and i don't think
but i don't really know why i loved it
maybe it's just because i just played
black ops 2 or whatever came out that
year and
the black ops games i actually like
their campaigns their stories but um i
thought the french level the paris level
which is actually very difficult to play
now post what happened right last summer
um i thought that was like one of the
most amazingly atmospheric that and the
the jet plane one where you went after
the mission and came back i remember
that the paris one wherever i think of
paris i think a modern warfare three
when the chemical attacks hit and okay
that's saying something because modern
warfare is a four-hour campaign right i
don't remember anything yeah but yeah i
don't know battlefield 3 i played a lot
of multiplayer i would just come off of
you know like the last one i played
while i was battlefield bad company two
and i just like you two i love those
games and three i think
kind of was scratching that same kind of
itch that i needed to get away from call
of duty with so i came around at a good
time because even then i think call of
duty exhaustion was setting in
um and three
kind of you know gave me that that more
nuanced multiplayer angle i was looking
for yeah baby and things levolved didn't
they iron
the deal evolved i don't know man
like i i did love three how many i want
to couch this first of all how many
hours do you think you put in the pilot
field three over 200 yeah i mean i'm i'm
i'm somebody who burns out after about
the one to 200 hour mark right that's
like i'll just get that feeling like
you've ate too much candy at that point
and i just no matter how much i want to
keep playing i can't but i have i know
people who could put a thousand hours
into that game easy
um
three was
great i loved it i thought it did
exactly what it needed to do the
multiplayer i think it did have great
rush maps and it did have great conquest
maps caspian border is i like i still
love that just but maybe mostly because
of the aesthetic yeah but yeah it's just
some really memorable maps i think even
their large conquest maps conceptually
were good um the armored kill expansion
was also really fun like bandar desert
was massive and fun and like
had so many different aspects to it
and their dlc's uh aftermath was
thematically very strong it had
scavenger mode which was really fun in
battlefield
so it was just there's so much done
right with that game and how did the
epic parachute jump on dama van peek oh
yeah
god that's so good just cannot believe
that they didn't do in four right like
how do you not love a thousand foot
parachute drop and then you know mean
you got some guy up there with like the
the barrett like firing all the way down
to the bottom of the map you know it's
just there were so many great memorable
moments from three's multiplayer and and
um like terrain highway like it was a
night map that you like went from
fought through a town at night and then
you fought into a city like again that
was the rush
influence yeah
four came around and they're like screw
it we're just gonna put everything on
every map and everything was so bland
because of it like rush crates were just
haphazardly put wherever the hell
somebody decided they were going to get
put sometimes you would like
run across a map and then run back
across the map and then run to like
there was just no like flow or anything
like caspian border when it was remade
in battlefield 4. oh yeah one of the
conquest points was a ditch
like why do i ditch it strategically
you may not understand as somebody who
actually you have had military yeah
one person here
um and also i guess the other problem
you could say with that was
you know this was a game that had a lot
of multiplayer problems with
connectivity
throughout its lifetime as well um
i hazard to ask but in the new
battlefield i'm guessing one of the
things you would like would be for
battlelog to just disappear forever
uh there are aspects of battlelog that
are good the
ability to go in and futz with your
character
when you're on the bus somewhere is
great like everybody loves to do that
like games fudson yeah games like the
division i was blown away they didn't
have an app like you know destiny had an
app and i was just always messing around
with my character and that
the ability to to think about and engage
with a game when you're not playing it
is always a plus
launching the game was a whole other
thing like all that battlelog did was
put a barrier between me and playing the
game right and i cannot tell you how
many times it literally took me 20
minutes to get my first game of the
night launched because i had to patch
battle log and then yeah
restart and then it was on the wrong
browser and then it wasn't compatible
with the browser setting and then like
it the the browser return was confusing
like what does it mean if i check none
what does it mean if i don't check none
like
am i getting proper return
on on the search that i put in yeah it
was always and then you would get it to
load and it would take five minutes yeah
i timed it one time it took me five it
took me five minutes to get into the
test server it's crazy so the these are
just barriers that don't need to exist
just get rid of them
and get let players hit start and get
into a match uh let's briefly talk about
the i guess the sort of side games uh
hassan in the chat making a good point
battlefield 2 modern combat i actually
totally forgot about this uh totally
different game to battlefield 2 single
player
campaigning i actually really enjoyed it
a lot did you play that one me too for
very different reasons i like the other
games but i remember getting into that
and i didn't even know what it was
really when my friend told me to play it
because i had been a you know big fan of
battlefield 2. i knew what that was all
about i knew why i played it all the
time for a couple years
and
modern combat was more it was it was
just this like wide scale single-player
missions yeah i remember and they were
they were well designed i think it was
actually a good game for what it was
going for it was like tank missions in
there and infantry stuff and yeah it was
a good balance between it was like the
halo balance between vehicles and or i
guess the bat the battlefield balance
between vehicles and uh foot combat it
wasn't
what i was expecting from the franchise
but what it was going for and i think it
nailed doesn't doesn't look too hot now
when you check out some of the footage
but uh yeah still a memorable game we
also had battlefield 1943 which was the
interesting digital only
version of like a sort of a pseudo
sequel to 1942 which had a bunch of like
a wake island and a couple of other maps
in there as well it was all right unlike
other battlefields that one
gave you these really like weirdly
satisfying rewards right for doing
anything yeah it's kind of like one of
those like yeah machines right it was
just like you'd like snipe some guy
across the map and you'd get one of
those call of duty like you're awesome
like
um
you know whatever there was only six
weapons it was very simplistic there was
tons of like terrain deformation
i think it's it was it wasn't meant to
be played for a very long period of time
yeah but it was a lot of fun
like while it was there
and then the last game to talk about i
don't think we probably missed one or
two here i know there was a bunch of
expansion packs for all these games we
we haven't gotten into secret weapons of
world war ii actually the expansion pack
for 1942 was was really tremendous and
worth a little mention uh but yeah let's
talk about briefly the game which opts
to allow you to just go
you're arrested put on your gun uh
battlefield hardline any fans here i
didn't play much of it at all i played
10 hours right i thought i remember the
initial reveal trailer it was weird i'm
showing that trailer with the stuff that
was going on what two years ago yes it
was very strange it was police brutality
odd taste and uh still is i'm like on on
the front pages so they should have gone
way more heavily into police brutality
they they took the easy way out
i wonder actually if that was part of it
was that they were going for this hawaii
5-0 woohoo we're just cops doing
whatever and then went oh no we should i
would someone will write a story about
that in the future i'm sure sure um but
in terms of how it played uh anything
did you play much around iron i know i
really enjoyed a lot of things that
visceral did with that game they
actually fixed a lot of dice's problems
there was some coding issues like sound
through floor bugs that always bugged
battlefield 3 people like you couldn't
tell what floor somebody was on when
they were running around so you'd hear
somebody running at you and you'd like
get your gun up and then it turns out
they were a floor above you like
visceral actually fixed a lot of those
problems they brought a lot of humor to
the game um the zip line and the
downtown map i thought were fantastic
like if you had a multiplayer actually
did a bunch of interesting if you take
any individual element of what they did
i love it like they had these really
funny one in 10 000 like animations
when you take it as a whole package i
think there wasn't
enough of it um it had gone through two
betas and then kind of was suffering
from beta fatigue right and there wasn't
enough content beyond that to really
hold people's attention
i also think that they should have done
they they shouldn't have
they should have done some battlefield
maps like a lot of the maps were very
tight urban maps
and they felt like they could have been
about twice as big as they were and i
think they lost the core battlefield
crowd just because
none of the maps really felt like
battlefield and you wouldn't have had to
have done all of them like maybe half of
them right and the other half are urban
but it's it's it's sort of picked a
style and and stuck with it uh for
better or worse and yeah that's actually
true i was kind of harsh on the single
player aspect but you're right the
multiplayer stuff was was pretty good
for a while it was enjoyable there
wasn't enough of it and they didn't do
enough of core battlefield
stuff to basically bring in the larger
audience which i think was sad because i
think they really did
do a lot of fun little things and the
one thing that i they better bring into
all but all the rest of the battlefield
franchise is the um the unlock tree from
hardline right where you just like earn
currency and you just buy whatever you
want what you want yeah like i do not
want to spend another 200 hours trying
to get my ecm jammer unlocked in my jet
while getting my butt handed to me by
like senior jet pilots and it's just not
fun to play with a new gun and get your
just get killed because you have to
start with iron sights it's just
that they need to take
from that game crazy franchise it's been
around a long time i guess not even that
long 14 years
are probably shy of 14 years at this
stage but some tremendous games in there
i really hope that whatever they show on
thursday sort of lives up to some of the
games that we talked about here because
it's been a half dozen absolute gems
like classics uh in terms of first
person shooters let's go around the
table final thoughts what is your
favorite battlefield game michael
maherty i think i'll stick to the my
roots with battlefield 2 okay yeah
although i'm i'm sure you might be
saying what i was thinking of as well
but yeah battlefield 2 is where i got
into it it's when i really started
playing a multiplayer game you know
because like counter-strike and now we
have not comparing counter-strike to
call of duty right but now we have call
of duty it's that fast-paced twitchy
just kind of lacking in substance
whereas battlefield's the opposite like
every time you do a multiplayer match
you had like some crazy story to tell
afterwards just pressing just
med kits yeah exactly every couple of
seconds make it who wants to make it
that was it and i would just run around
like an idiot throwing these
these
you know mres at people uh yeah that
that was battlefield 2 for me what about
yourself ryan predictably bad company
too but i will say if dice doesn't hate
money they should just do an hd remaster
of battlefield 2. because a lot of their
great maps in three
were just remakes of battlefield 2 maps
and i think
people would absolutely buy hd
battlefield 2. yeah just re-release it
i would yeah
give me a ticket for an airplane
i just love battlefield vietnam so much
it's like it goes down as one of my
favorite i was in a clan i was in the
irish guards tig i was their qe pilot
for about a year or so when i was like
i don't know 14 or something um and i
love that you could even just like put
your own mp3s in a folder and just like
play whatever the hell you wanted so
it'd just be like flying in with like
death tones playing or something just
your helmet lopsided in the straps
exactly yeah huge glasses are fogged up
it was so much fun we'd spawn and
everyone would get in the huey and you'd
basically like shuttle across the
landscape yeah hug the flag because all
like six of you or whatever five of you
are in it and go tick tick tick tick
tick tick tick tick tick tick and then
go to the next one and then like there'd
be a battle at point three between two
enemy huries yeah and everyone would
jump out when they thought it was gonna
explode it's like one of the most
memorable experiences for me ever so
yeah probably vietnam for me classic
games uh let us know what you think is
your favorite battlefield or what just
is your favorite battlefield or what is
the best battlefield and what would you
like from battlefield 4 in the comments
sorry battlefield 4 battlefield 5 or
whatever unnamed just battlefield
battlefield they're going to go back to
the start uh in the comments below god
i'm going to go play some battlefield
vietnam now
uh we are having a long hour show here
talking about first-person shooters
we're clearly
soothing our nostalgic lands a little
bit let's talk about something a little
bit more
uh current shall we uh the overwatch i
guess early access started yesterday the
open beta is getting rolled across
global territories as we speak i think a
lot of places probably haven't oh yeah i
thought it was thursday oh is it
thursday it's happening i think may 5th
okay what day is today it's may 3rd
third oh it is may the 4th so i think
it's may 5th for all three platforms
early access soon enough everyone will
be able to go and pick it up themselves
uh let's have a little chat about it
briefly i've been playing it on the beta
for what seems like an eternity now um
are you reviewing it for us or not do
you know i will be yeah okay for
for all i know that's the plan cool and
iron have you played any overwatch at
all i played some overwatch yeah cool
played some of the beta uh so
what are your thoughts on it so far mike
as somebody who you're gonna review the
final product i feel like we're
basically playing the final product yeah
um minus anything they change with the
progression and the skins and just
overall i don't know
just servers map rotation running
of life stuff perhaps yeah this game is
it's got me hooked um
i think because of our jobs it's tough
to really play one game all the time
anymore yeah which you know it's you
know it sounds like such a thing small
thing about yeah
right that's it's not a big problem at
all but like i'm looking for like
counter-strike i'm looking for you know
we have rocket league but i'm looking
for that shooter i can just go back to
time and time again and it's really got
me hooked um each of its characters it
feels like they could have a game
revolving around them i think these
characters are so nuanced and so
detailed and so so much thought put into
each one
uh and then when they collide the
balance is so great and you think about
each match a different way depending on
who you're playing or what the objective
is there's so many like minor things so
many major things you don't even notice
just because it's such a such a chaotic
looking game but then a certain point it
kicks in when you know a few characters
and you know what you're doing you know
what your team is trying to do where it
just starts making sense in such
different ways each time and yeah i'm
looking forward to putting a lot of time
into this yeah i'm totally with you in
terms of like we were talking about
battlefield vietnam earlier and then
there were games like you know
counter-strike 1.6 i was big into i
loved source i love team fortress 2.
there was these sort of tentpole
first-person experiences online games
that i sort of
we all have right when we look back at
our our history of our our favorite
games and this is as close to one of
those as a game has come in a long time
like probably like call of duty
for modern warfare like this is a game
that i can see myself playing for like a
year or two um and it's because of what
you just said it's because there is such
a i mean like you can never tell right
when randy picture was up talking about
battleborn and we were seeing these
games like battle cry and then overwatch
was coming up from blizzard and there's
a sort of a cynical aspect where you're
thinking oh you know what it's just
somebody else who's trying to get into
another multiplayer game which they're
trying to hook in people to play forever
and it's going to be like a moba or it's
going to be this like super reductive
thing like oh there's all these
different characters that look different
so i kind of went into overwatch being a
little bit cynical thinking you know
what they're all going to look you know
people are going to love to cosplay as
these people but i'm not going to care i
just want to play a goddamn first person
shooter but these characters like
they're so they're so individual and yet
all interesting like i genuinely mean
all i think maybe soldier 76 is the one
that i'd least play like playing the
least but i still enjoy playing him yeah
across the board 21 of them are so
interesting to play like junkrat i
sometimes play with i love pharah and
widowmaker but i'll just like jump all
over the place i don't mind when i'm
last into a bret into a team and it says
oh you need to play as assault or um
support it's like fine i'll pick lucio
or i'll pick mercy if the if the map
works and i think it's like
you know obviously that team had a big
lot of trouble with what they went
through at titan and i think they had a
big weight on their shoulders to really
make something legitimately great and i
think overwatch is like legitimately
great yeah it's i think scott's been
playing a lot of battleborn i played a
decent amount of battleborn and that's a
game where scott described it probably
earlier on the show i didn't catch it um
he was saying you know it's easy to
learn or sorry easy to master but it's
difficult to learn whereas this one is
it's difficult to do both i mean it's
the characters it's easy to learn but
it's difficult to master because these
characters they initially seem really
simple but some of my favorite
characters you know it's this fine
balance between
mastering these five characters but also
just it's so fun to try someone out new
and it's still
the game itself is very inclusive and
how you play it because it at the end
it's not it doesn't show kill death
ratio it rarely shows kills um it'll say
like if you were a support it'll say you
healed this much team damage and then
everybody votes on like what was the
most useful and i think that's a really
cool way of showing how this game works
and that you don't just have to be
widowmaker sniping people in the face to
help you can be
zarya my favorite character and
shielding people shielding yourself
using your ultimate to create these
choke points where everybody just starts
like junkrat starts lobbing grenades and
you know while mercy revives your last
teammate it's it's it's just like
refined chaos and it's so cool and how
it unfolds differently each time and
what initially seems like a simple game
yeah i think the way that they're
tracking your score and what information
they choose to display or not display to
you it came up in your interview
was a really good design decision i
can't tell you how many games
encourage bad player behavior because
they're so obsessed with their kd or
they're so obsessed with their point
total
and it actually will get players to be
selfish and not play the objective
and them choosing what to show and not
to show based on making players more
emotionally connected to
just focus on the objective like don't
worry about it don't worry about your kd
don't worry about these other things
like
those are very forward-thinking design
decisions that i think encourage good
player behavior totally and they even
did things like not including team
deathmatch is also a part of that where
it's like you could easily put team
damage in here you don't you know you
probably wouldn't play as a support
character but they literally do not want
any situation in which you get back into
like bad habits i think team deathmatch
is is the death of objective based
gameplay right because
what usually happens and has happened in
a lot of shooters is you have an
extensive unlock tree and you have some
great modes and you have deathmatch and
people realize that deathmatch is the
quickest way to get through the unlocked
tree and by the time they're done with
it they're like whatever i'm just keep
playing deathmatch yeah yeah yeah and
you kill the objective modes
i've seen that happen in battlefield and
lots of other games so
it's very brave to not have death match
and it's a decision that i i think more
games should follow and in like we i
guess when this first came out we sort
of frame it in terms of a lot of new
games and the sort of new things that
are happening in in first person design
especially in online competitive maybe
not shooters but just online competitive
play but this is like such a best of uh
you know
so many first-person shooters i mean
widowmaker has the grapple hook from
quake 2. you know junkrat is basically a
team fortress grenade spammer uh you
know lucio runs on walls like so many
games you've got tracer who's basically
you know
corvo from dishonored right diva is
titanfall like
all of these characters
you know even like widowmaker's
sniper rifle feels like it's a head shot
home when you it's like counter strike
it's like you can hit people in the body
and then certain at a certain point
you're playing against people who really
know how to play widowmaker and i was
like oh no i need to go for headshots
yeah there's people that will grapple
hook and then mid mid grapple just stop
sniping in the air will like snipe you
including that little like cool down
thing that happens with it i will say
you do have to like a style of gameplay
that revolves around choke points a lot
yes because that's one it's one very
specific thing about this game
um whereas in battleborn the maps are
very open
and strategically if you're not if
you're not successful pushing one side
of the map you can shift to the middle
lane or the left lane
whereas in this one i feel like you live
or die by certain choke points in this
game and
the the deciding factor a lot of times
are some of the characters who can go up
and over buildings yes and get behind
the enemy team but there's also a lot of
players you're just like you gotta push
through this thing yeah and if you can't
do it match is over yeah totally it's
very like team fortress 2 in that
respect or team fortress classic or
whatever quake world team fortress if
you want to go the whole way back yeah
however far you want to go back that's
why overwatch is really i'm
traditionally a an offensive player in
in battlefield so offensive yeah i
offend people when i'm shooting them i i
guess it's always offensive right
this game i actually like playing
support characters a lot probably the
most um you know zarya i think she's
classified as a tank but she's
very much she is oh yeah
in her aesthetic and just how she plays
but she's very much support in the way
she she could shield people and like
you're just talking about chokepoints
i'm as someone who's really into like
multiplayer level design
it's cool that her ultimate is
essentially them letting you almost
create these many choke points yourself
with the black hole yeah pulling a bunch
of people in um i think it was the one
match where i really realized how cool
this game can be it was the payload we
were almost there we were escorting the
payload and i was tracer and i was just
playing her like uh like a dual wielding
first person shooter game um and then i
realized like oh no i could i should be
a pest right now i should just go back
to where they're spawning almost i don't
have to kill anyone i just have to just
annoy them keep them occupied shoot them
one about to die back out to the next
room keep running away shoot them just i
and it was awesome because i was just
you know like i was skirmishing wasn't
killing anybody and i know i i know they
hated me for it because they couldn't
get back to like my team who was doing
their jobs and you know we had a winner
widowmaker above us we had pharah just
kind of watching the payload from above
we had winston circling it and then i
was just off by myself going rogue and
kind of just essentially annoying the
other team it's amazing the memorable
moments that you get in this game remind
me so much of playing games of cs where
you've got like
4v1 right and you're watching spectator
mode in like cs italy and
you know the other player just figures
it out just like isolates one of them
done gets two of them done like a random
grenade throw that just kind of works
out and then you know there's a fight in
a you know in a market and there's
melons flying everywhere and then they
end up winning like it's got those
moments but on such a like
moment-to-moment basis that you know
it's like i i kind of feel like without
any game especially when you have
preview i'm so hesitant to talk them up
because
there's a sort of thing where it's like
oh you're oppressed so you've got early
access to this thing you've been playing
it forever and you're playing under
great conditions but we've been playing
overwatch so much over the past couple
of months and i have like absolutely no
hesitancy in saying that i think this is
one of the best online first-person
shooters that's come out in like a
decade i keep it's almost i keep having
to remind myself it's not out yet
because i played it so much it's only
for three weeks it's not until may 24th
yeah so if you're a crazy person by the
130
edition yeah or you get the origin
sedation for 60 um you're not gonna be
playing it for for
officially for until until then but you
know just like hearthstone you're able
to just go play it openly now i guess or
soon enough yeah i mean
you're saying counter-strike and i agree
with that comparison the one game i've
been comparing it to my friend asked me
because he saw overwatch and he's like
this just looks like a moba to me like
like what battleborn is doing with a
couple of their gamers like no i was
like just think of team fortress 2 but
instead of five classes or whatever it
was six you have 21 and they're all much
deeper um the map there's more maps and
he's like all right you already you had
me right and again i'm reviewing it i'm
just tempering what i'm saying yes but
i've had fun but
i don't have a final opinion in the game
but
i also have been playing a lot of it and
i'm hooked on it all right well there
you go what's your thoughts on it you've
played it sort of you dabbled yeah it
depends where you're coming from if you
are like a battlefield
guy who likes this type of game to me
siege landed with me
better just because i love
i love how in like the intensity of
siege and the fact that it's the first
game in a long time that
you're not making a lot of kills and
every kill that you make matters a hell
of a lot
to me that's more exciting than just a
really well done
moba style shooter but that that's just
because i like tactical shooters and i
like battlefield and i like the sandbox
better than i like the chokepoint like
it's funny did you play brink
oh not not much at all because i feel
like brink tried a lot of this stuff and
for some reason it didn't land with
people and it seems like overwatch is
trying very similar things
and connecting with people yeah so like
you're right yeah the player movement
stuff was very much in the early days
for first person shooters back then as
well so i
you know i think that i know a lot of
people love this game in the office
choke points are not for me i like
open layouts where i can make decisions
that aren't just go through that right
or die
you know and that's what i like about
siege and that's like about battlefield
and i've got a lot of games to look
forward to this year too like
i mean like titan you know i don't know
when titanfall 2 is going to happen
we're going to find out at e3 zoom 3 is
a couple weeks away as well yeah but i i
respect other people's enthusiasm for
this game right now
and i did enjoy what i played yeah i'm
going to play more siege though
interesting interesting week for for
first person shooters interesting month
uh and yeah maybe hopefully an
interesting year as we get to the end uh
with call of duty uh let us know what
you think are you gonna pick up
overwatch yourself are you gonna jump
into the open beta uh interested to hear
from people who are playing it this week
for the first time actually let us know
what you think in the comments
below all right
we've got one out of section before we
give this thing away by the way uh we're
not giving this away alive nathan drake
here
let me just take his head off again just
take his head off again now
you can win me i'm from the old game but
don't worry about it i look kind of the
same look at that it's got a great sun
tan on
and envious
uh
friends
i thought i really thought
yeah well yeah crunch he'll break his
nose off and it'll be worthless
we're good all right ss pikmin is
watching it
uh we are about 39 days i believe from
the electronic triple 2016. e3 is
approaching let's have a little chat
about it let's do an update i kind of
feel like we should do this every week
until until e3 starts
with a couple of uh news thingies
happened this past week a bunch of
things happened over the past couple of
months actually is that uh nintendo sort
of slowly crept out of e3 a couple years
ago and did a press conference anymore
did their nintendo uh their event and
then their you know the directon and the
treehouse stuff which was seemed seemed
to be very successful i guess uh ea have
decided to put out completely
activision have decided to do their own
thing as well everyone's kind of like
doing their own off-site thing um like
devolver i guess development was the
first person to do that uh disney as
well won't be there um
um and then we just had news this week
that nintendo are only going to be
showing one game which is basically
zelda right yeah it must be the wii u i
mean whatever you need to show yeah
so
there will be no new pick ross game i
guess at e3 this year uh what do you
guys think about this we've
you know
e3 has ebbed and flowed it sort of got
back to its roots in the past couple of
years there was that year at santa
monica where they downsized and
basically everyone thought that was
awful and it ended up going back to the
moscone again
what do you think about an e3 without
really much of a nintendo presence at
all and ea in activision which basically
takes up most of the south hall i think
it's kind of a little bit down on it
mike or do you think it'll be all right
i'm pretty down on it i think a lot of
us were pretty sure they were going to
do something with the nx
yeah and now it's delayed till 2017 yes
at the very least they said um and i'm a
huge zelda fan and that's the one thing
that they're doing that i'm really
looking forward to well it's one of the
things they're doing that i'm really
looking forward to but i don't know
unfortunately i feel like in the past
four or five years nintendo has been
taking a back seat as it is to to like
everybody i mean bethesda came out last
year with their first press conference
and
you know fallout 4 showed is one of the
cooler things we saw bethesda's press
conference last year was probably the
best press conference of the weekend and
they came out of nowhere and
i haven't been that excited about
nintendo at e3 in a long time and i'm
not crazy surprised by this the more it
sinks in the more i just kind of feel
like it it's all the piece it makes
sense
all right what about suffering i think
you have to separate as a game
journalist e3 the location with e3 the
what we learn right e3 the location has
dabbed and flowed over the years but to
be honest the show floor is probably the
worst place to experience a game for a
gamer like as a gamer you want to be in
a quiet living room with your surround
sound system and a controller and just
be engaged right it's a fair point like
i had a dream my entire life that like i
would love to go to e3 some year right
and the reality is that like it's great
to go and every year it's like an
absolute privilege to walk into that
that hall but stuff like pax is so much
better for actually playing games like
e3 is all business and massive massive
lines and you don't really get access to
a lot of stuff so as a you know when you
go there as a journalist you would
actually rather be in a hotel a quiet
hotel room and be able to like
experience the game as the developer
intended it because nobody designs their
game with like a thousand people
bumping into you and screaming and like
lights flashing it's really a hard way
to engage with with video games so
the content that's gonna happen at e3
this year i'm excited about like we're
gonna get a lot of shooter sequels we're
gonna
maybe like you know somewhere in the la
area have a playable version of
battlefield here about titanfall 2
dishonored potentially dishonored
sequel i want to know where mass effect
andromeda is at right i mean there's a
lot of stuff that we can learn
and
if i'm sitting at a computer and
watching a live stream or in a hotel
room i don't care how i get that
information that's what makes me excited
as a gamer and most like i mean let's be
honest it's not open to the public so
most people don't
walk around the show floor really really
care about what happens on the show
floor yeah like no matter what the
information is going to come out in its
own way and perhaps in a better way
because for the longest time the
microsoft and sony conferences would
sort of cram in everyone else into there
and nobody had their own space to talk
about it whereas now we'll hopefully
have it like sort of petered out across
the whole week yeah you're right like ea
are gonna show off all their stuff like
they always do um bethesda are going to
do their own thing as well so it's
interesting yeah a couple of people in
the chat um talking about how you know
comic-con same thing kind of happening
uh companies are avoiding these big
things or at least doing their own uh
thing diablos x saying i mean even
square enix had their thing for final
fantasy you know and for everything else
so a bit of a bit of a sea change uh
what are you looking forward to mostly
actually mike because aaron's kind of
talked about a bunch of things he's
looking forward to i'm excited to see
what nintendo will show of zelda
assuming it is zelda but i'm also
excited to see more of uh dishonored 2.
um i really like designer game informer
had their cover story yeah today and i
haven't gotten the chance to look at it
but i'm really excited to read through
that because i really like dishonor the
first one i know you've been playing
recently too um aaron and i
i really am interested to see what they
do with emily because she's a cool
character in the first game and now that
she's kind of usurping corvo's role as
the protagonist or as one of the
protagonists i forget what the specifics
are uh that's probably the one i'm
looking forward to most to see what they
do with that what arcane does with that
because arcane is such a talented studio
and they did such a great job kind of
bringing this new ip out that was kind
of weird when we first saw it and it was
this person like teleporting around like
tracer like you said and uh
now we are kind of on the cusp of the
sequel and i'm hoping they can follow
through with it i'm very much looking
forward to sort of what the console
manufacturers have to say about
i guess you know playstation with the
neo the 4.5 i want to see like you know
playstation vr if we've got any like
bundles and prices and stuff like that
and then it'll be interesting to see if
microsoft's you know flinch in relation
to that as well do they
get off their arses and talk about doing
the same thing do they double down on us
do they make a whole new type of xbox
perhaps getting do they you know that
space between consoles and pc that they
keep on closing did they sort of merge
those two things now that windows 10 has
kind of gone across the board um
one of the things that i would like to
see people talk about which it's just
quality of life is
uh the the the cross play idea
for a second i thought you said like
cross play
yeah i always hear lacrosse the sweet
pair it's all that looks like you hear
the crowd cheering permanently
uh cross play like yeah end of fiefdoms
get rid of it like i want to play with
whoever on whatever um if i'm on my pc
at night and i want to play with my
friend who's on xbox one or ps4 i can't
tell you how many times i've been
isolated from my friends
just because like we had different
consoles and different systems or
like your ability to play the same game
on multiple platforms just that sort of
freedom of choice could be such a good
quality of life improvement for gamers
yeah if they can work it out that pushes
and pulls in so many directions because
sometimes you don't buy a game because
you're like oh my friends won't get it
on that platform so i won't i'll i'll
wait and get it here uh or maybe i'll
buy the other console but then sometimes
it actually helps them because you're
like oh my friend has that console so i
better get that console so that we're
all you know working in the same sort of
ecosystem uh but you're right like the
there is definitely a push towards that
i mean rocket league you know is now
across the board so and also like
late in the life cycle of games when
player populations dwindle there can be
that effect where they get too low and
then it just tanks because there isn't
enough people to play titanfall you've
consolidated all those people into one
pool and suddenly you've got multiplayer
games that have much greater longevity
because you can maintain that community
for a longer period of time yeah there
you go i guess we'll have more updates
in the coming weeks let us know are you
excited for e3 what are some of the
announcements you're looking forward to
more than anything else stick them down
there in the comments below all right
that's a show we ran about
3 30 it's the longest we've ever we're a
little bit late hashtag blaine tay we're
going to get those uh those t-shirts in
as well thank you so much to goop shoe
for sorting this out with those things i
can hear him screaming in there right
now probably uh thank you so much eric
for getting the show up and running
appreciate it have you ordered your
blind type t-shirt
yeah it's pretty good what color did you
get just white white mm-hmm yeah i don't
know gray is there a gray does it gray
yeah maybe it's gray i always get great
t-shirts yeah there's no white you liar
the white was the original like concept
image of it maybe that's what i was
thinking of but it was gray sorry goob
yeah don't worry about it that means i
misspeak can i do it like ace ventura
just knocked out and then walk around
with him like a
man scarf
for e3 sure yeah why not let's all get
this [ __ ] i'll do it yeah he'll love
that just
just walk around the office and
constantly
knocking today's lights out so we can
wear it yeah that sounds all right okay
that sounds ethical and safe
he's leaving right now probably thank
you so much to everyone who watched in
our twitch chat uh watched on youtube
and of course watched on gamespot.com
and thank you everyone too for hosting
oh there it is hashtag blame today pick
it up yourself it's on teespring look at
that great thing it's got i think it's
got something on the back as well i
think it's got blame you written on it
too uh comes in a bunch of colors green
gray
blue red
another gray so many different types of
gray how does it not have his home phone
number on it i mean if you're going to
blame tay where do you go that's where
you're going to blame him could at least
put an email address or like a return
address on the front of it as well uh
but yeah there you go thank you so much
everyone putting the show together mary
kish richard lee eric tay and our new
boy mr jean luke
seipski scipikisky scythe kiki
all right i'll have to have to get used
to that um yeah for putting the show
together today really appreciate it
everyone uh we will be back next tuesday
do you have any stream after this
actually eric
negatory sir negative no stream after
this but we'll have more of course on
the game spot twitch channel so hit that
follow button and for us here in the
lobby we will see you next week tuesday
2pm pacific have a great week play some
video games and we'll see you next time
adios
you